would you recommend a person who suffers
from emotional spontaneous shopping stay
out of the shopping malls and I'm hang
up and let David wait a second you don't
get to hang up yet that's too juicy but
wait a minute he knows the answer David
you know the answer well what's your
recommendation do I just not bring as
much cash into a Walmart or a shopping
mall or do I not go at all I want to
know David what does this spending look
like are we talking about hey I go to
Target and next thing I know I've spent
$500 on a credit card is it I come back
because it's the Lexus Christmas to
remember and I bought my wife a new car
like how deep does this go I walk into a
shopping mall with say $400 my intention
is to buy one item and leave but you
know how a shopping mall is the next
thing you know you see this you want
that you may be with a woman she sees
this you want that she wants this and
the next thing you know that 400 is gone